so the institution that you mentioned uh
that i that pops to mind for me is
family um and and i i recently wrote an
op-ed about the struggles among boys and
men
that are unfortunately now kind of
self-propagating where if you have men
who are failing then you have lower
rates of family formation you have kids
who are being born to single moms i
think it's up to over 40 percent in the
u.s now there are adverse outcomes among
boys in particular who are brought up in
in those
uh types of environments um so i i'm and
i'm uh i don't know if uh about your
personal situation i'm a dad myself
uh yes uh how old are your kids my kids
are nine and eleven wow i've got a nine
nine-year-old a six-year-old uh and i i
have said to people
yuval i never would have even considered
running for president if not for my
experiences as a parent
where when our first son was born uh he
was autistic we did not know that uh it
was a very very difficult baby uh and
toddler uh and the strain on the family
was
extraordinary
um and
i remember thinking i have no idea how
people could get through this
alone
because uh in our case uh you know it
was my wife evelyn and i um and i i
ran for president because i thought i
might be able to help the situation for
people who are struggling uh at that
level like at home uh um with the family
um and so that this is to me
like a building block as you suggest
there's no more important institution
um and i proposed something that um i
took a little bit of heat for but mainly
people liked i said hey
i think we should just pay for marriage
counseling for anyone who wants it like
if you're struggling in a relationship
and you want to have someone uh help
you with your relationship with your uh
partner
that's a social win like if you stay
together it's a win you know like i
could do the math on it if you wanted to
but um you know it et cetera et cetera
um so uh that's like the the first
institution i think of and for whatever
reason um we're in a strange time where
i think if you say something about
pro-family um like that that gets
freighted politically in certain ways
one of the worst things about the
character of contemporary partisanship
is that because everything has to be
politicized
things just sort of fall on one side or
the other of our politics and people in
one party feel like they have to be
against something because people in the
other have made it their big issue
and this certainly happened with family
issues i mean
the idea that to talk about providing
support for families
is to take a stark polarized partisan
position is i think bizarre
we can certainly argue about how to
support families and i think there may
be just some distinctly left or right
ways of thinking about that but the
notion that there ought to be a role for
society as a whole to provide support
for family formation and for
family durability
um it seems to me should be
uncontroversial
um it certainly is controversial and you
know it's just
the character of this moment is that
essentially everything is controversial
i mean you can't take any position
without it being identified as
uh
in one sense or another a rejection of
the opposite party
um i think family is the foundation of
society that
and and that's a that that's not um
that's not because of our kind of
society in particular it's because of
what it is to be a human being um yeah
that feels fairly universal yeah i mean
you know human beings are never born
alone they're always born in families
and some one way or another
that's how we're formed to be what we
become so you've been a a part of
uh
politics and public life in some form
for uh gosh not to date you but you know
like going on a couple of decades
and during that time there's been a real
erosion maybe even collapse of
institutional trust yeah um how do you
see that decline as tied to this
polarization that you're describing
which i i'm sure you'd agree has gotten
much much worse in recent years yeah
yeah absolutely i mean i i there's no
question that we're living through a
period of declining even collapsing
public confidence in institutions that
much is uh it's almost a cliche by now
to say so and and the data behind it is
very very strong
decades of of public opinion research
it's not just political institutions um
it's it's every kind of institution
from from
religion to uh
to big business to banks to the media to
universities and certainly the
institutions of our government just have
less of the public's confidence now
than they used to
um you know there are a variety of
reasons why that happens i mean in some
ways it is over determined but there are
some reasons that are especially
distinct to our time i mean i think you
know
one kind of universal reason for
mistrust is corruption and there's
plenty of corruption in our time but
there's plenty of corruption in every
time it doesn't quite explain the
trajectory
similarly incompetence you know
sometimes you don't trust an institution
just because it doesn't do its job very
well and there are always reasons for
that kind of mistrust but i think one
thing that's distinct in our time is a
sense that our institutions are not
forming trustworthy people that is as i
talked about institutions before you
think of them as shaping a certain kind
of human type and oftentimes the reason
you trust that human type has to do with
boundaries that are set by the
institution
right i trust my accountant not so much
because she just knows all the tax laws
i hope she does but because there are
things an accountant would never do
would never sign her name to
and
in that and for that reason i can trust
what she does do
um you could say that about a lot of
professionals in particular but a lot of
people in general who are shaped by
institutions it's the constraint that
gives us trust
there are things a journalist who's
really a journalist wouldn't say without
checking there are things a scientist
would not claim without evidence you
should check on that journalism one
night i
know a journalist
if we were to trust institutions if we
were to trust journalists if we can
think back to a time when we might have
that would have been the reason why and
i think in our time and you know as as
what you say by journalists suggests in
our time we've lost the sense that
people are actually constrained by these
institutional boundaries and instead we
have a sense that people use the
institutions that they're part of as as
platforms for themselves
you can see it in journalism uh you know
a lot of a lot of political journalists
now
if you check in on twitter right now
you'd find some elite political
journalists just building their own
brand not acting within an institution
within layers of editing and
verification but standing on top of
institutions i'm a new york times
reporter and so you should care what i
think
and acting as individuals
liberated from those kinds of
constraints those people become very
hard to trust um and
a lot of our institutions now
essentially elevate individuals that way
rather than constraining them in a way
that makes them trustworthy that's true
in the media it's true in the academy
it's true in politics a lot of people
now run for congress not to be the human
type that is a legislator but to build a
personal following to build their brand
to build their social media following or
to get a better time slot on cable news
and what they're doing is not
recognizably institutional
and therefore is very hard to trust i
think a lot of our loss of trust has had
to do with that and it's connected to
return to your question it's connected
very much to partisan divisions and
polarization because a lot of what
people do with that with that prominence
that they get by standing on top of
institutions as platforms
is participate in the culture war
and so
um you know being a prominent pastor
means you get to show that you are part
of this team and not that team being a
prominent professor means that you have
a platform for uh expressing a affinity
and solidarity with your own team in the
culture war
obviously it happens in the media
obviously it happens in corporate
america and in politics and so in that
sense i think the weakening of
institutional constraints has a huge
amount to do with the intensification of
polarization and partisan animosity in
in this century well you're like one of
these old school anti-corruption
institutionalists where you're like hey
you know you're representing this uh
very important uh organization or argust
body so you should never
be beating your chest in that way i can
see why you didn't like trump
but yeah no kidding i mean here's a guy
who was not shaped by any of the
institutions that normally shape our
presidents right he's the first
president we ever had who had not held
any public office before of any kind um
and i resemble that but continue
what that means is that he doesn't take
it he doesn't take his cues from those
formative political institutions and
i think that that has expressed itself
in everything that he had done before he
had basically been a performer
um and he wanted to be president to be a
performer on a bigger stage and that's
what he was
and you know i i think that ultimately
we we always have to be in order to have
any kind of integrity
in life we have to ask ourselves given
the role that i have here how should i
behave and maybe that role is i'm
somebody's father or i'm a professional
or i'm a neighbor or a friend
um
given that how should i behave in this
situation that's what a that's what a
person with integrity asks themselves
and i think that this kind of
deformation of our institutions that
encourages people to just think of
themselves as performers
takes away the incentive to ask that
question and the result is just a lot of
irresponsibility
[Music]
you